we are getting a breathtaking new look
at the Titanic shipwreck check these
images they are 3D images of the ocean
liners Remains the most detailed ever
made researchers you've used
submersibles that skin every millimeter
of this wreckage it was last year they
captured more than 700 000 images from
every angle that is cool experts are
hoping the 3D scans can provide more
insight into how the Titanic sank after
it hit an iceberg in 1912. so a
documentary is being made about this
project but when you see that kind of
detail I mean it really showcases this
ship in a totally different how massive
it was yeah agent Chan I think you did a
great job well done Nancy I accepted the
mission possible